robert saul has gotten his chance before
eric b enemy he's the new head coach of
the jets it was pointing in that
direction a couple of days ago
when salah had his second interview with
the jets but then something happened
he left the building and yesterday chris
sims and i were wondering what was going
on because
you let the guy out of the building
there's a chance somebody else is going
to hire him before you can but last
night the news broke
that salah is indeed the next coach of
the new york jets succeeding adam gase
they go the other
direction they go with a defensive guy
peter i don't know how you feel about my
theory let me run it by you you may
agree you may disagree
i'm a firm believer in this age of the
nfl to hire offensive coaches especially
with the jets because what do you got to
do you got to fix the quarterback
and if you're going to keep sam darnold
and salah is going to bring in mike
leflore matt's brother
to fix the offense and if he fixes sam
darnold what's going to happen mike
lafleur is going to be a head coach now
you got to find another offensive
coordinator
and sam darnold's got to go through that
unlike a sean payton and drew brees who
have been joined at the hip for 15 years
i would always err on the side of an
offensive coach
because it's all offensive creativity
and development and quarterback
quarterback
quarterback so solomon end up being a
great coach may end up being a hall of
famer they may end up finally winning
another super bowl
in new york to put a trophy next to that
51 year old one that they've got
somewhere
in in storage but it if they have any
success mike lafleur is going to be
coaching somewhere else just like matt
lafleur got a job quickly
as an offensive coordinator mike lafleur
is going to be the next one to go
well i think you're assuming that when
mike lafleur goes if he does go
because they've had great success that
whoever the quarterback coach is
who is running mike lefleur's offense
wouldn't get the job
and very often the quarterback coach in
that system does get the job
and mike all i can say is this you know
the new york jets and their legion of
woe
is me fans would sign
tomorrow for this organization to have
so much success
that their offensive coordinator gets a
head coaching job somewhere
that would mean that they would have
gone deep into the playoffs or won a
super bowl or something like that so
i you know look my feeling is if it's if
all things are equal
and you've got a quarterback who is
needy yeah sign the offensive guy
and you know everybody i think thought
when arthur smith went in there
for his second interview or you know
whatever that was
everybody thought okay well now it might
be leaning toward arthur smith
but you have to get the guy absolutely
categorically who's gonna walk in front
of a room and command the room
a couple of years ago bill parcells told
me when all these coordinators
and brilliant offensive coaches were
getting hired
and i don't say that uh you know
sarcastically
i i mean it i mean i i think some of
these guys are really really good but
parcells said you know that's really not
the most important part of the job
the most important part of the job is
standing in front of that team
commanding that team and being able to
walk into the locker room
and sit by anybody's stool which
parcells used to do for
45 minutes a day and sit by anybody's
stool and just talk to him
and look him in the eye and tell him you
know what you're not doing it right now
you're not doing or you're saying hey if
you keep playing this way you're going
to get more chances and just
having those those uh
you know areas of communication that are
so
so so important and look everybody
i've just described robert solomon you
know from
everybody on the 49ers who know you know
who
who've had to deal with him um he's a
great communicator
and he's also a commanding presence so
look
i i i think the jets got a good guy
and they'll be okay on offense i think
the first thing i thought of when he got
the job and i think back to other
moments involving guys like brett favre
tim tebow adam gase when you go into
that
room with all the reporters there that's
your first chance to work the room now
that's not going to happen
in a pandemic you're not going to have
150 reporters jammed into a room and you
walk in and you say excited 50 times or
you're looking all over the place like
gase was when he was just kind of
overwhelmed by the moment
but it's still going to happen it'll be
a video conference
but that will be the first taste that
the new york fan base and the new york
media gets
of robert sala and it's the ultimate
pass fail i mean they're already
you know look the ba you're all you're
the back page darling already they're
calling him mr green the take on mr
clean because he's got that bald head
like the guy
on the mr clean uh product it's
that that's that's what new york is
going to do and he's got to be ready for
it and
in some ways i mean we don't know much
about him because
coordinators don't have that big
presence but
he's got the chance to be the most
charismatic coach of the jets since rex
ryan
and i think they need a little rex ryan
right now peter they need a little bit
of that flash they need a little bit of
that sizzle
to go along with the football
you know i i just think of this you know
robert sala probably has been the most
charismatic coordinator of the last
couple of years in the nfl
i remember uh a couple of years ago i
think it was the seattle game
on monday night football in 2019
you know the huge seattle san francisco
game
and robert sala and i'm doing this for
memory i think i'm right
was on camera 106 times that night
and so you know he's he's used to being
you know you have your head coaches and
you have your coordinators
well robert solo was right in the middle
you know and so to me
i just look at i look at him and i look
at a guy
who's used to the spotlight he took a
defense to the super bowl
if not for hey mike if not for the last
eight minutes of that game the first 52
minutes
of that super bowl robert sala looked
like
tom landry and vince lombardi combined
you know
so all i can say is that i think the
jets
did a good thing in not just worrying
about the defense
but in getting a program coach
and a good voice of the franchise
he's going to really enjoy that
part of it to be the spokesman
that everybody in new york is talking
about when you're hot
and everybody in new york is talking
about when you're cold too
it's funny living in new york uh and
i've lived here
either new york or new jersey for most
of the last
uh 30 years or so and what's very
interesting is that
there's just this intensity that is
almost as hot when you lose is when you
win
and so he's going to have to adjust to
that
you know and i remember this year mike i
requested after the jets broke their
schneid against the rams
i requested to talk to a player or two
or or adam gase after the game
and the jets refused and they basically
said you know
it's only one win they don't want to do
it and they don't want but what it was
i think is adam gase being all ticked
off because everybody had just belittled
him
and his team so much for so long that's
what a coach
has to get used to when you coach in new
york
you made a great point about all the
times we've seen robert sala on camera
and that
is great organic marketing of the coach
and i know there are people around the
league
who are salty and resentful about this
notion that
you watch a 49ers game and it's
constantly solace alas alasala
like he's he's directing the game and
he's saying
put the camera on me the camera's drawn
to him
you know i mean you've got the whole
sideline you can choose from if you've
got a guy there who is a passionate
involved and interesting coach the
camera's gonna find you
and uh during the game you're just
coaching your team so
there's a natural charm there's a
natural charisma
that does make him interesting and
that could make him an even better
presence for the jets
that's what they kind of need right now
obviously they need a good coach
but they also need someone who is going
to
play better with the media than gase did
gates just wasn't interested gase just
didn't care
gates just wanted to coach his team you
could tell by
his demeanor anytime he spoke he kind of
had that shoulder thing and he
had pulled down and you know can we get
this over with so i can get back to
coach my team
you can get away with that if you're
bill belichick and you've got pelts on
the wall
you can't get away with that until you
do and i think
saul is going to be a much more
energetic
natural charismatic presence who isn't
going to be
upset that he has to talk to the media
he understands it's part of the job and
he's going to engage it and if he does
if he embraces it
and he brings the same kind of passion
to it that he does the coaching i think
it's going to work well
as it relates to making the connection
with the fan base
we mentioned that mike lafleur is
expected to be the offensive coordinator
you may have seen a couple of tweets on
the screen
in approval from first first-rounders
mackay becht in the left tackle and
quinn williams the defensive tackle so
the jets now have their coach they've
had their gm and joe douglas he's been
working on building the team
from the inside out not the outside in
so you know they still got major pieces
they need especially if saul is going to
have a defense like the one he had in
san francisco
but this is reason for hope in new york
as they see the patriots dip
they can feel like maybe they've gotten
a little bit of a lift and maybe they'll
meet in the middle at some point
over the next couple of years hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports